[Musique]
baky à baba moussa a passé huit mois en
prison en libye elle a été arrêtée alors
qu'elle tentait de rejoindre l'europe
les autorités libyennes nous ont arrêtés
moi et mes deux enfants en pleine
méditerranée
pour nous mettre en prison
d'abord celle de keryan
pendant les six premiers mois à partir
d'octobre 2010 cette annonce j'étais
enceinte à ce moment là depuis un mois
la santé de maquillage se dégrade en
prison manque de nourriture et d'eau
elle est dangereusement déshydraté sa
grossesse est directement menacée
quand je suis arrivé en libye la prison
c'était terrible vous lancerez laissé
mourir de faim et puis pour avoir
quelque chose de l'extérieur il fallait
dépenser beaucoup d'argent pour
sortir de là et reprendre le bateau pour
traverser
il fallait tout payé en même temps ta
famille ne peut pas tout payer en même
temps
grâce à ça à ses côtés son amie la plus
proche dans leur nouveau foyer zara ali
mohamed arrivé dans cette maison
réservée aux réfugiés atteint de maladie
mentale il ya six mois elle aussi est
hanté par les sévices qu'elle a subis en
prison pendant trois années
interminables
mon corps maintenant chaque fois que je
le vois je me rappelle que le joli et me
faisait ce qu'il voulait des coups de
couteau dans les jambes jusqu'à
m'utiliser comme un cendrier il écrasait
des cigarettes sur moi
zara est toujours sous l'effet d'un choc
post traumatique makhija elle a
développé un trouble bipolaire à l'issue
de sa détention pour lequel elle suit un
traitement les deux femmes se
soutiennent mutuellement
[Musique]
en 2018 quand je suis arrivé je voulais
seulement partir partir partir comme
sarah je ne voulais rien entendre je
voulais juste partir et c'est pour ça
que j'ai eu tous ces problèmes mentaux
je ne veux pas que ça ravive la même
chose que moi j'ai peur qu'il se passe
la même chose avec zara et qu'elle tombe
malade comme moi
toutes les deux ont bénéficié du
programme e tm mise en place par le hcr
un système d'évacuation d'urgence vers
le niger deux migrants coincés en libye
les autorités nigériennes leur octroie
le statut de réfugié ils peuvent alors
demandé leur réinstallation en europe ou
en amérique du nord tous veulent quitter
l'afrique je veux partir je ne sais pas
où mais je veux partir je veux retourner
à l'école et je veux savoir où est ma
famille aujourd'hui
je ne sais même pas s'ils sont en vie
plus de 90% des réfugiés évacués de
libye dans le cadre du programme e tm
quittait le niger moins d'un an après y
être arrivé mais certains restent
coincés plusieurs années à niamey une
attente qui fragilise la santé mentale
de tous les réfugiés
[Musique]
mais plutôt des facteurs déclenchants
l'attend peut être
alors j'ai donné pour le scar tech 1 40
ans ils n'ont pas un point civils
risquent de développer le psycho parmi
les psychoses vous le savez les traiter
à des séquences chronique qui sort qui
ont un traitement à l'entente voire à
vie
julie sadler agents administratifs du
haut commissariat aux réfugiés monte les
dossiers des candidats à la
réinstallation les demandes aboutissent
neuf fois sur dix mais souvent ces
réfugiés abîmé par un parcours éprouvant
ne comprennent pas les délais ou les
reçus
donnez nous s'il vous plaît autant
d'informations sur votre parcours que
possible si vous ne vous souvenez pas de
quelque chose ce n'est pas grave
simplement dit le mois
il faut être très clair dès le départ
avec les réfugiés
ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
mettre en place d'un jour à l'autre
ils la prennent dès le premier jour ils
sont également mis au courant du temps
que prend normalement la procédure tm
sachant que les particularités de chaque
cas vont déterminer si le traitement
prend plus ou moins de temps
au final c'est le pays d'accueil qui
décide si la personne est acceptée ou
non
près de 4000 personnes ont été évacuées
de libye grâce à ce mécanisme depuis
2010 8 mai selon les nations unies
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
migrants il serait encore victimes de
violences
[Musique]